so with knockout the cabin now being out
worldwide I thought I'd revisit one of
my favorite M Night Shyamalan movies
that is Unbreakable
[Music]
released in the air 2000 this came hot
off the heels of the director's Smash
Hit The Sixth Sense and still a little
which I only learned last week that he
was the screenwriter for now that's
arguably M night's biggest twist but
unbreakable definitely feels like it
packs one of his most devastating ones
with a reveal at the end involving a
character that we grow to love in this
video I want to bring you a big
breakdown on the film The Hidden details
in it and also some of the many reasons
why I think this movie is a masterpiece
it's a film I saw when I was very young
and it stuck with me over the years as
being one of the best deconstructions of
a superhero origin story I actually
think that unbreakable was ahead of its
time and with it being released in 2000
it didn't really get the appreciation
that many people have for it now dropped
at the start of the Millennium this came
before the wave of comic book movies
that now make up most of our culture and
going back to it I was blown away by how
good of a job it does at crowning some
of the extreme things that we see in
films today though Nolan is often
credited as being the first person to
really do a grounded superhero movie it
has to be said that M night got there
first and it's difficult to think of any
that other sincere now when this was
released a lot of us poured over the
special features and in them M night
went over the original plan which
eventually saw coming to fruition almost
20 years later in glass M Knight has
always said that this was supposed to be
act 1 and in hindsight we know that
split and glass were Acts 2 and 3. the
original script for the movie actually
featured Kevin Wendell crumb and when
discussing split on the happy sad
confused podcast M night went over how
he originally appeared in Unbreakable
David was going to discover his powers
and whilst this was going on he'd hear
of a serial killer out in the city Kevin
would kidnap a group of young girls I
can split and at the train station David
would bump into him at this point it
would trigger a vision of the three and
the Final Act would be in following
Kevin to the house at pops about the end
of the movie instead of saving the
children from the psychopath like what
we get here David would stop Kevin at
the house and he'd rescue the character
Casey M Knight said he actually ended up
using 20 pages of the original
unbreakable script in Split so it's not
like we ended up losing this now in the
Final Cut we actually get some setup of
Kevin and at the stadium David bumps
shoulders with a woman pulling her child
along he hears her screaming at him and
the script actually goes over the scene
that was originally meant to be in the
movie at this point we caught a vision
of the pair in the kitchen with him
crying and they both looked down at the
belt hanger and an extension cord now
there are some things still left over
from the original script though and at
one point we hear Elijah's mother
talking about how there's two types of
villains but he says there's always two
cards there's the Soldier villain who
fights the hero with his hands and then
there's the real threat the brilliant
and evil Arch Enemy who fights the hero
with his mind this is obviously
referencing The Horde and Mr glass and
it's very much foreshadowing how things
will play out down the line now we start
off the film with a big block of text
discussing how many Comics are so per
year and how many Comics the average
collector has this very much grounds as
a film and almost feeling like it's a
documentary and it mirrors a text at the
end which tells the audience what
happened to Elijah I remember wondering
whether this was actually a real story
or not when I saw back in 2000 and we
didn't have the internet back then to
check if it actually was it just gives
the movie this feeling that it's not too
removed from our own world which is
Central to this film's themes Elijah
believes that there has to be an
opposite to him out there and this is
brought on by his obsession over comic
books and the way comic books are framed
or used to inspire the cinematography in
the film throughout the movie we see as
several characters appear in doorways in
rectangular windows and these are meant
to mimic the panels that other pages of
a comic book this is seen in the opening
when we see a group of people standing
in the middle what appears to be a
doorway in the Philadelphia department
store whether as the shot continues we
realize that this is actually a mirror
and I love the way we're first
introduced to Mr glass through the use
of a glass object we quickly realized in
this shot that we're actually looking at
a mirror pointed at a mirror and we pan
down to see Elijah's mother and him
wrapped in a blanket Amira's glass and
Reflections are some yet constantly
appear throughout the film they of
course represent Mr glass and they
appear at numerous points throughout the
entire movie when we see the next spot
of his childhood we can catch Elijah
said in his room watching TV and we see
his reflection in the glass screen
display when we're first introduced to
him in his Art Gallery we also see the
character reflected in the glass of a
piece of art containing the line work of
the first comic he ever read when David
meets glass for the first time we also
go from the street outside his store up
to the glass window and then look
through to see the pair coming face to
face paneling is also laid out to look
like a comic book again tying back to
the earlier point now as for David we
first meet him on the East rail 177
train he's leaning against the glass
window of the carriage further
foreshadowing how the pair are opposites
to each other when he goes back to work
he opens up his locker and we can see
the character reflected in the mirror
there and there will cause mirrors of
each other with them existing on
opposite ends of the scale this is why
mirrors and Reflections are used
throughout the movie and they
subconsciously Hammer home the idea that
the pair are opposites to each other now
inversion is also something that appears
throughout the film huge it adds to
seize well for pointing out all these
examples and when we're first introduced
to David this is Through The Eyes of a
child with her head upside down Davidson
Joseph also watches the TV upside down
in the next scene and when Mr glass
falls down the stairs at the train
station his head is upside down when
Elijah picks up the comic on the bench
he also opens the box to find it upside
down and lastly when Joseph watches his
dad on the bench he comes in from the
top when looking down met him now on the
train the conversation is framed once
more and this rectangular shape that's
some of how the movie opens it adds the
idea of the scene being like a comic
panel and we see David returning from a
job interview in New York here he's in a
green shirt and green is the color that
the character Dons throughout the movie
he of course wears it on the rain jacket
at the end and his security jacket and
shared at the stadium are green Arthur's
locker and kitchen are green and just
like how characters and Comics have
colors that they tend to stick to in
their uniforms he does too green was
also chosen because it's associated with
life-giving properties such as grass in
nature which makes David a force of good
throughout and the idea of green is
reflected in Elijah who wears purple
throughout we see this in all his
clothing and when David takes the
envelope of his windshield this has a
purple inlay even his mother wears it
whenever she appears throughout the
movie and this can be seen about the
start and the end of the film The Comic
that he picks up on the bench comes in a
purple box and it's possible that the
two colors on it giveaway who will be
David's enemy the hero is wearing in
green the world around them is purple
and the lettering of the title is in
Orange the villain at the end of the
film wears an orange jumpsuit and in
this scene at the bench Elijah is also
wearing orange the cover is very much
pointing out the three colors that we
need to look out for in the movie
without being a strong focus on green
orange and of course purple now active
Comics is of course a play on Action
Comics which is the first comic that
Superman debuted in Shyamalan took a lot
of inspiration from comic book tropes
and the name David Dunn contains
alliteration like a lot of other
superhero names as Peter Parker Clark
Kent and so on and so forth which
inspired him now to choose the
character's name also worth noting that
jaguero wears a sort of mustard yellowy
color which is what Kevin later ends up
in in split and glass he is the villain
that David fights hand to hand tying
back to this comic book in the first
film David's very much going through a
midlife crisis at this point and feeling
unfulfilled in his life career and
marriage the movie is about him finding
a purpose and and come the end of it
once he's accepted his powers everything
falls into place we discover that David
could have been a big league football
player because of his abilities but he
chose love over his chance at super
stardom David's wife Audrey said that
she'd never marry a football player and
after a horrific car accident he
pretended to be injured so that he could
stay with her however his love for the
game made him still want to be involved
with it unless he became a security
guard that works at a stadium I think
this haunts him though and having to
watch players on the field likely makes
him more depressed because he thinks it
should be him out there and the
characters first scene he meets a sports
Rider on the train and she very much
represents the possibility of another
life he's clearly trying to have an
affair or some kind of hookup as he
hides his wedding ring which he ends up
pulling out once the chat up lines don't
work clearly she's a symbol of not only
his football dreams but also the
marriage that he thinks is causing his
unhappiness and he could see her as
something new and also fulfilling she
even asks if he's in the football and he
says you like
foreign
this is him clearly lying to himself and
the movie's filled with the idea that
he's constantly repressing the truth she
says she's out there to cover a young
and upcoming Star and we actually see
this character later on as we watch
Joseph playing football with his friends
Joseph actually gets into a fight with
this guy's cousin at school and I like
that this subplot ties back to the
beginning I'm meeting this player from
Temple University he's a cornerback
this kid is six foot one 210 pounds he
runs a 40 in 4.3 seconds he's going to
be a god
Potter's cousin
he's starting cornerback jumping
he's going pro on the draft
they say he can run the 40 and 4.3
seconds
I've heard
who was pottering another guy
they're messing with this Chinese girl
in the dressing room
you can't let bad things happen to good
people right
now David then makes a joke about how he
wants to become a synchronized swimmer
are you looking for any male
synchronized swimmers
this is ironic as the character's
weakness is of course water later on we
also learn Audrey's favorite song as
Prince is soft and wet and her favorite
man goes pretty soft when wet
David also wears a big rain cover as his
costume and this of course protects him
from water and as the train starts to
crash we get David looking around and we
learned that Kevin's father is actually
sitting further up the carriage there
are two big points to this in splitting
glass I touch upon this moment and it
brings everything full circle because he
resides in the train yard as The Story
Goes because Kevin's dad left on a train
Evan's dad didn't just take any train
and not come home
next stop
the trilogy is called the East Royal 177
Trilogy in this accident's the one thing
that ties everything together now we go
to Joseph watching TV and nothing
grounds this more than being in 2000
than having him watch The Jerry Springer
Show the news report comes with a nice
and at least direct throughout and Shout
Out sees world again who pointed out
that in the top right we can see a four
that's meant to look like the Fantastic
Four logo now from here we go to David
in the hospital once more framed in a
rectangle in the front of the frame is
the only other Survivor and we watch as
he slowly bleeds out leaving David as
the sole survivor this scene was
actually used for the trailer of the
film and going into it pretty much no
one had any idea about what the movie
was actually about now he steps out in
the hallway and we see families waiting
to learn what happened to their loved
ones and there's definitely this feeling
of survivor's guilt shown in David's
face he returns home and he and his wife
are both shown in doorways as they speak
to each other David says he doesn't
think he got the job but he says he's
still moving there showing how he feels
like he wants to get away from it next
we see the memorial services for the
families of the train crash and a
memorial for this crash was originally
meant to appear in Split but M night
fell it would just give the game away
David then gets an open limited edition
and that's smooth egg white card silvery
text embossed
very nice no
no let's look at Paul Allen's card
anyway back at work we see him boxed up
in the reflection of his mirror cut to
him standing in the doorway asking the
secretary about his sick days and then
standing under an archway his boss then
appears to him in a doorway and it shows
how much attention that M night was
paying to the shots also there will be a
lot of moments where I just point out
people standing indoors but bear with me
now at a hammer home how broken his
marriage is we cut today with sleeping
in bed with his son before he goes to
his wife standing in a a doorway jinx
cartoon Elijah and we catch him sitting
bitter that he's not able to have a
normal life his mother very much forces
him to guard into the world as she knows
that if he stays it shouldn't that it
won't really be a life for him he can
see why he becomes so obsessed with
Comics because the self-aspirational
idea is that one can be more than what's
being given to them the name Elijah also
pulls from the Bible and in that there
was a story involving the character in
which he challenged several other men of
Faith to prove their God's power he told
them to pray to the one they believed in
to calm down and set their Ultra and
fire and none of them were able to do it
Elijah then doused his in water and asks
God to show them why he was the true one
and the altar then sparked up and burned
away I'm definitely butchering that
story from my memories of Sunday school
so I apologize for that but the idea of
using water could be the reason that M9
picked the name for the character now on
the bench his mother says they say this
one has a surprise ending interestingly
I heard that knock at the cabin doesn't
actually have a twist ending and the
biggest M Night twist now is that we got
an M Night movie that doesn't have an M
Night twist now we cut to Elijah who
makes a comment on the movie itself the
thing that makes it very very special
is its realistic depiction of its
figures he refuses to sell the comic to
the parent because he's gonna give it to
his kid and bloody Gatekeepers I can't
stand them however it shows just how
much Elijah values his high art he
doesn't see comic as being something
that's for kids and instead to him
they're myths and legends that are worth
preserving he classes them in the same
bracket as works of history and this is
why he hangs them up in clear view of
Scrolls from ancient Egypt also
important to bear in mind that this
actor is talking to that's actually M
night's cousin and we also get a cameo
from the director later on now when he
meets David he goes into the tragedies
that have hit the city and in hindsight
we know that he was Behind These the
city has seen its share of disasters
I watched the aftermath of that plane
crash
I watched the Carnage of the hotel fire
if there ever was a fire on the floors
one two or three everyone in that hotel
will be burned alive now this movie
actually came out before 9 11 but one of
the reasons I think it's aged so well is
because it picks up on the despair that
we all felt after that there was
definitely a time when we hoped and
prayed for a hero and many of us looked
at ourselves and other regular people to
step up and Inspire others I'm probably
not waiting my point as well here as I'd
like to but in retrospect I think
there's a reason why this movie didn't
do so well in release but why it stuck
with us for decades it's the mood tones
and themes that it presents which end up
playing into the way that we look at the
world now the movie actually
underperformed to the point that the
studio refused to Greenland a sequel
which is why it took so long for us to
get one in the end M9 pretty much had to
pitch split as its own thing which is
why it feels so Standalone now David
says this morning was a first morning
that I can remember that I didn't open
my eyes and film
sadness he believed that the card would
finally provide him with a purpose but
now he's crushed thinking that it won't
however unlike David Joseph's clearly
wrapped up in the possibility that his
father could be a superhero and the
night David goes into the cupboard to
make sure that he's gonna still air
Joseph later points his at his dad and
this is because he believes that the
bullets won't work this is actually
based on something that happened to
Superman actor George Reeves and a child
ended up putting one at the actor at an
autographed signing like David Reeves
managed to get him to lower it after
saying that he was invulnerable and he
added that firing it would cause the
bullet to Ricochet and hit someone in
the crowd a moment before this we catch
David reading a paper chronicling the
crash to the right of the article we can
also see one talking about a fatal car
accident which is somewhat reminiscent
of the one that he walked away from
beside the gun he ends up taking out
some news articles including the one
reporting on his accident and he's lived
with a lie so long he's almost
reassuring himself yeah that it's the
truth this is very much his reality and
I know people criticizing the film are
like well how wouldn't you remember but
you try and think about something that
happened 20 years ago and you can see
how the memories start to get foggy now
this article is written by Robert
Holtzman and he's a production designer
that worked in the art department for
the film we get another doorway scene
with Audrey but it's important to bear
in mind that at this point the pair
haven't actually been in the same room
as each other on screen at least they're
very much living in a world where
they're unable to connect and this is
shown through all of these early
interactions she asks David if he's been
with anyone else and she says she wants
to start again and sees him walking from
the train as being a second chance that
entire event should have been his death
but it very much became a second life
for the character in which he found a
new purpose and we then go to the
stadium and we see David at work Elijah
has been caught using a fake ticket and
this is just one of the many things that
point to his deceptive side the next
scene is the pair framed inside some
green stairway railings creating the
panel effect here Elijah says that he
became a security guard because he
instinctively we chose to protect other
people you also see the demonstration of
his sixth sensibility to perceive
incoming threats it's very much a spider
sense and this gives him precognition to
avoid danger do you know how he he saw
this guy because I didn't see anyone
sorry that's a crappy camouflage job now
Elijah and David stand in the doorway
and the former later confirms that he's
able to sense danger Elijah even puts
himself in danger to do this showing how
cemented he is in his beliefs we get the
character going to his car and can see
the inside of this has been outfitted
with cushioning because even a minor
bumper crash could lead to him being
fatally injured Elijah's shot so he can
see him through the glass window and
when he turns on the radio we hear into
the investigation of dream 177 being
warehouses the city council has stepped
up plans to pass a bill requiring higher
standards for in for inspection and
maintenance had these security measures
been in place from the start he wouldn't
have been able to crash the train and
it's seen more as an accident rather
than an attack now there is some irony
in the fact that David's Journey began
on a train and Elijah falls down some
stairs at a train station trains are of
course used to take you on a journey and
into somewhere else David starts to find
his purpose after the train ride and
Elijah finds his after realizing David
managed to sense the gun now in the next
scene David does a literal test of
strength but how much can you lift mate
write it in the comments below how much
do you lift and also use that super
strength to smash the like button and
subscribe for unbreakable breakdown to
break apart your favorite movies and
also your favorite TV shows now in a
juxtaposition of the scene earlier in
the movie we see a doctor telling Elijah
all of the broken bones that he has this
is a complete opposite to what happened
with David earlier and whereas he was
told he didn't have a scratch on him
Elijah has to spend months in a
wheelchair whilst going through intense
Physical Therapy yeah he meets Audrey
who helps people at sports injuries and
well just injuries in general she's seen
first time what comes from playing
football and this explains why she
doesn't want David or Joseph playing it
just do you know how mad your mother
would be if she knew you were playing
football Elijah also says he asks too
many questions when he's nervous and
throughout the movie we've seen as he
does this even in the comic shop he kept
asking questions and though he puts on
the facade of being a tough guy we know
that he questions people to disarm them
so that they aren't threatening towards
him those asking the questions are
normally the ones in control of the
conversation and this is the only Power
that he actually has he lets off the
terrorist attacks once more to order
Audrey and it's once more the character
going through his past crimes almost
like a villain monologue 172 died no
survivors a hotel fire downtown 211 died
and Israel trained derailed seven and a
half miles outside the city 131 died
One Survivor now at the stadium we see
David starting to believe any attempts
to sense if he can pick up on people's
crimes this gives us the M Night Cameo
and he returns them both splitting
unbreakable I can put my hands down now
isn't very neat is he walked right
through the trash one of the tenants got
murdered offside and people are on edge
hey do I know you
did you used to work at the football
stadium him talking about one of his
tenants dying recently also ties into
split and we know from that that he was
the landlord of Kevin's therapist he's
very much turned his life around in
those movies and it shows how David even
had a positive effect on the City by
just embracing his powers I used to hang
out with some shady types down at the
stadium in my youth
turned it around positive thinking this
is something that superheroes have
thought of us doing and Elijah even says
these are mediocre terms Mrs Stone
people are starting to lose hope what
about this idea of being inspired also
has negative effects we learned Joseph
had a fight with Potter and another kid
because they were picking on a girl
Joseph fought him but it didn't go too
well and he's completely bummed out by
not having his dad's abilities when
talking to what I believe is the school
nurse who learned that David almost
drown when he was younger and this is
another blow to him M night wasn't
carrying the drugs he thought he was
because he stashed there man the
drowning makes David think that he isn't
super powered David then breaks his news
to Elijah who's just as devastated that
he's lost his purpose it's important to
bear in mind that this movie is an
origin story for both him and David with
a pair learning why they exist now we
see Elijah in a comic book store and
it's built with Classics like Ultimate
Spider-Man Neymar or is it Namo now
Daredevil and even a member of Staff who
later appears in glass the actor that
plays the guy squirting him out of there
also shows up in the third film now we
can see him as the comic book store
owner now in between this we go to
Joseph playing with superhero action
figures I believe the one on the right
is the same as the one from the cover of
active Comics only this time he's
wearing a mask might be a reach but
David is very much hiding the truth now
like the man wearing a mask it's not a
good Easter egg we'll move on now whilst
David and Audrey go on a date Elijah
realizes that water is actually David's
Kryptonite this is in an issue of Sentry
man which is of course a play on the
century the way it lands in his lap
makes it inverted and this is similar to
the active comics issue from the start
of the movie on the day David tells
Audrey that something just doesn't feel
right and this is why it's so powerful
in the end when he comes home and
carries her upstairs Upon returning home
he finds out that he got the job in New
York but he does turn this down I think
this shows that he doesn't really regret
any of his choices and even if he got
another chance at the high school car
crash he'd still make the exact same
decision he Ventures out to wear the
cars from the crusher being kept and
here he remembers what really happened
on that night bending steel with his
bare hands the first person he saved as
Audrey and he realizes he would give it
all up for her that night David goes out
once more to the train station again
bringing the idea of trains being a
significant part of his journey amongst
the crowd he sees people stalk his sins
and I love the way the M Night brings
Focus to colors in this moment they
really stand out against the drab
environment and they pop like the colors
on a comic book page lastly he
encounters the man in the orange
jumpsuit which is also pulled across to
the t-shirt that he has on in the vision
scene David follows him through the rain
with a beating down on him however the
overall stops him from getting wet I
love the way the scenes in the house of
film were there being no music at all
and instead we watch as he makes his way
through it slowly and silently it's so
atmospheric and it really grounds these
moments in realism now several things
happening doorways with us getting David
entering the bedroom before he then goes
to the cupboard after freeing them we
get a moment where he goes to the
parents room and this is shot
beautifully with the doorway in natural
environment of the curtain creating
their own panels showing him and the
kid's mother it's really Next Level
cinematography and it adds so much to
this scene David is then pushed over the
edge and he lands on the pool cover you
see just how devastating water can be
from him and this is one of the most
agonizing drowning scenes I think I've
ever seen in a film watching him wrap up
in the cover and knowing how helpless he
is will have you holding your breath but
he's saved by the two kids this allows
them to be heroes as well and it shows
just how inspirational that David has
become in the end he kills the murderer
and I think this is such a raw and
visceral death scene there's no
over-the-top fight no insane
choreography and magical powers it's
just a guy holding on and refusing to
let go his hold is unbreakable and no
matter how many times he's thrown
against the wall or elbowed in the
stomach he just holds on
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
everything
a David carries Audrey up to bed and
then I later said that they somewhat
referenced this scene when Casey's
carried out of the underground both
allowed them to move on to a new part of
their life and David finds comfort in
Audrey after saying he had a bad dream
on the date he said he realized that
things had changed between them when he
had a nightmare one night and didn't try
to get comfort from herb and after
realizing his purpose he's now changed
his Outlook he shows Joseph the
newspaper on a call and might be a reach
but the orange juice against the green
shirt could be M Night linking back to
the colors from the night before anyway
this article is written by Nicola
Marcella who is a production team member
that worked on the film in the comic
shop he watches David meets Elijah's
mother and she talks about how the
villain's eyes are larger and they give
a skewed perspective of the world I
don't know if Samuel L Jackson made his
eyes wider and bigger in the movie but I
know people who think that he did so
that it would tie into this line however
it's important to bear in mind that the
one I shot we get in the film is of
Elijah's and this is skewed due to the
angle against filmed at finally David
goes in the back room with him Elijah
presents his hand fully aware of the
truth it's gonna reveal we see a number
of his attacks and on his computers
several schematics this includes an
outline for the Brooklyn Bridge and I
did wonder if this was a little nod of
the pairs team up in Die Hard with a
Vengeance which took place in New York
now as we zoom in we see plans for the
football stadium showing that even if
the train hadn't have happened that they
likely would have crossed paths down a
line because it was their fate on the
wall or a newspaper clippings including
how a baby survived a mudslide in Mexico
and as we learn in glass there are more
people like David in the world next to
this we see several books on
microbiology and chemistry and it's
clear that Elijah has been completely
obsessed with this we cut to another
collection of newspaper articles and
even see one for a killer virus set
loose in an airport which the less said
about that the better now there's one
that lists a man being pulled away from
some wreckage a youth being the sole
survivor of a plane crash and a tone are
being found and about that ran into a
pier in hindsight he's helped to build
the universe out and it's reports like
this that Elijah has hung on to he said
he wanted to hear the words that there
was one sole survivor without a scratch
on them and these words finally brought
David out Elijah has now found his
purpose and for the first time in the
film he smiles finally having found the
happiness he was searching for that ends
the movie and this final scene still
gives me goosebumps to this day whether
it's the cinematography storytelling or
the score to me unbreakable is a film
that I think still stands as one of the
best superhero movies ever and hope
you've enjoyed coming back to it with me
interestingly M night would follow this
up with signs and a what what was the
alien weakness in that water so nice
connection to this I guess and you know
we had to end the video with the worst
Easter egg possible anyway let me know
your thoughts Below in the film and make
sure you subscribe to the channel you
want something else to watch then we
have a video on screen right now I'll
see you on the next one I love you take
care peace